uh one of the biggest problems i think i
have with the educational system
is that when people graduate college
they stop learning or they they think
they should stop learning um you know
they've just been
it's not their fault it's just they've
been told every year every month to read
this do this homework do that subject
now cover this and they've been given
huge swats of free time and then all of
a sudden all that time is taken away and
very traumatically you're thrown at the
workforce and said now get up in the
morning to be at work by eight a.m you
can't leave your desk until six or seven
pm you've got to grind on this even if
you think it's nonsense that you're not
learning anything um so then the the
then the work environment spends a lot
of time beating uh you know your love of
learning out of you and not that you
ever had the level of learning because
in school it was an autopilot so i think
what's really important is to develop a
love of learning that is more important
than anything else it's more important
than what you learn
uh it's more important than uh you know
what school you go to and it's more
important than what job you have
keeping your intellectual curiosity
alive is really important and the only
way that's going to happen is if you
learn what you love if you read what you
love if you do what you love
the moment you are doing it because
somebody else is telling you to do it or
society's telling you to do it you're
just not going to stick with it
but the good news is that even if what
you're learning to love even if what
you're what you're what you're learning
is impractical i still think it'll pay
off in the long run
economically and the reason is because
eventually you just get good at learning
and so then you learn new things so if
you like to read you'll you'll read new
things i feel like if you watch podcasts
even if they're fluffy podcasts that
you're not getting you're not getting
much learning out of over time you'll
just find yourself listening to more and
more podcasts you get bored of the same
old topics and you move to something new
so just keeping that intellectual
curiosity alive is far more important
for your economic and intellectual
well-being
than it is to to learn something that
you don't frankly don't want to learn if
you're struggling through a subject
unless you need it for graduation drop
it
go learn something that you want to
learn
[Music]
so
[Music]
you